hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar automating culture and high
content imaging of 3d organoids for
in-vitro assessment of compound effects
i am marie stone of labrutz and i'll be
your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by molecular devices to learn more
visit molecular moleculardevices.com we
encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
i'd like to now welcome our speaker dr
aksana sirenko
senior research scientist at molecular
devices
oxana you may now begin your
presentation
thank you so much
so hello everyone i'm oxana sierra
encore senior scientist from molecular
devices and i will be talking today
about eye content imaging and automation
of organoid research
so why there is an interest in 3d
biology
there is a great unmet need for
biological model systems that better
represent human biology than 2d cell
cultures 3d biology modules projected to
have improved correlation to human
physiology and they also at lower cost
as animal models
so biology now trends towards increased
complexity of resin models 3d micro
tissues organoids and organ and chip
represent transition between cell assay
to tissues and organs
futility of 3d biology is expected to
expand for disease modelling and also
compound testing so technologies and
instruments should also increase
complexity and capabilities to enable
scientists to work with those more
complex biological systems
so what are their organoids
those are 3d biological micro tissues
that contain several types of cells
they represent complexity organization
and structure of a tissue
and they resemble at least some aspects
of functionality of tissues
so this is a relatively novel field in
cell biology and even so
3d biology was used for cancer research
and also
the developmental biology in the past
the official
milestone creation of
3d biology is
gut organized from adult intestinal stem
cells that was a publication in 2009
another big milestone is 2013
when cerebral organoids were derived
from induced pluripotent stem cells
here is a general organoid workflow
so the cells which give rise to
organoids could be derived from primary
tissues like gut lungs or kidney and the
rebuilding tissue in a culture example
is a cleaver slab gut organoid
also organelles could be derived from
induced pluripotent stem cells or stem
cells and they culture and develop into
multiple cell type organoids with
organized structure
example would be gnoblic lab brain
organoids
so the most typical method for formation
organoid is the cultures cells in
material domes
typically cells just pre-mixed with
material and droplets placed into 24
well plates or other plate format to
form a solid droplet like a dome
then media added on a talk of this
structure and then growth factors
promote growth and differentiation of
those organoids inside the material
so organic culture is a long process
which includes several steps with
different media
during this process cell phenotype needs
to be monitored
typically this process
used for understanding developmental
biology and tissues
so this long process has a lot of
technical hurdles and also opportunity
for method development
so the methods and readouts are still
evolving they include microscopy
viability assay morphology marker
expression pcr and also secretion study
or viral infectivity
so essay is now at low throughput
but methods and instrumentation
are currently evolving to facilitate
research and enable high throughput
screening
so i will be talking about high content
imaging of organoids and also
development of methods for automation of
cell culture of organoids
so this is screening workflow for 3d
organoids which in general resemble
general screening workflow for any cell
types it includes culture in cells
in microtiter plates in this case in
nitrogen
then those cells are treated with
different compounds or growth factors
then they stained and imaged
so for image and 3d structures like
organoids
you should use confocal microscopy
so by using confocal microscopy you can
take this stack of images through the
volume of organoids and also through the
volume of material
and then that this stack could be
converted either compressed into
a 2d projection like maximum projection
similar to what's presented here
or it could be converted into 3d space
then
the analysis could be performed either
in 2d or 3d
and that analysis would give number of
measurements which would describe and
characterize the phenotype of organoids
and also cells inside of organoids
they will
describe area volume diameter depths
intensity or shape of organoids they
also can describe and count individual
cells within organoids either in 2d
projection or in 3d
and they would count different cell
types life and dead or with different
markers and also area and volumes
distances and intensities
so for imaging we use image express
confocal hdai system
it has seven channel laser light source
which present brighter images and also
flexibility
it also have a spinning disk confocal
technology automated water immersion and
also in carta image analysis software
which has machine learning algorithms
so in this example you can see how laser
illumination greatly decrease exposure
time and also the time for your essay
also it provides
great flexibility for the choice of
chlorophyll or for different assays
i will describe several examples of
organoids
so i will start from lung organoids lung
organoids were grown in madrid gel
from
primary lung airway epidermal cells
in material domes for eight weeks
we use reagents and protocols
from stem cell technologies
so here is a non-organoid workflow which
starts from 2d culture that then
organelles form in material domes
followed by growth and differentiation
and then compound treatment and
experiment
in this slide you can see images of
different magnification of organoids so
you can use low magnification to capture
entire dome these organoids inside
you can use higher magnification to
capture individual organoids or
individual cells inside organoids so you
can see here the
great change in the size and development
of organoids over from the weeks of
development
so interestingly since organoids are
hollow inside you can actually image
through the organoid objects and also
you can image through the material layer
and capture number of organoids one on
the top of another
so you can also convert it into
projection image
right here this is maximum projection
so you can
image live organoids either in
transmitted light or using life staining
in this case like viability stain or you
can fix organoids and then restain with
different markers
here is a phalludine stain
mitochondria stain nuclear stain and you
can use a lot of different markers
so here you can see example stepping
through this stock
and you can
see
structures inside the organoids so these
small cavities kind of converted into
bigger lumen
so here is projection image of mature
culture you can see organoids of
different size
here you can see one image which
actually cuts through different
organoids so you can see those cavities
inside
we've used different stain in this case
we use etidium homodymer stain and
nuclear stain ethereum homodimer for
dead cells
here we use mitochondria stain in red
so here we have used uh following stain
for fixed steroids fixed organoids and
also mitochondria stain you can see
those complex structures inside
so here we have used transmitted light
and we collected time lapse and you can
see
movement of cilia here
and interestingly this
small organoid was kind of rotating for
days in the same place
so you can see different
size and
complexity of shapes of organoids and
try also to mimic some disease modeling
like inflammation by addition of
inflammatory cytokines so we have had 13
f alpha il1 and interferon and you can
see here
the partial dense and disintegration of
organoids
so we develop also different methods for
analysis of these images so in the
simplest
case you can use projection image
and
just run live that image analysis
algorithms here you can see image of
object and here analysis masks so this
is for life cells and red for dead cells
and you can define number and
percentages of life and dense cells for
different treatments and also measure
those response
so we have also used machine learning
based analysis in transmitted light
so when you use the
algorithm it can
do a pretty good job to find round
objects but then you can further train
this algorithm for even better precision
so to do so you have example images and
you trace it around
for the objects which is you design as
organoid and also you
define the area which is not organized
and after just few iteration you can get
very good analysis and segmentation and
you can do
different measurements on those objects
like count and identify area
diameter or in
density
so here is example how we use custom
model editor in metaexpress software
which allows to find organoids here we
typically do it for
the per stain as the objects and then it
allows to find
nuclei and individual cells or cytoplasm
or mitochondria inside of objects so
here example of cytoplasm
so then you can actually
take higher resolution images
which define all kind of
individual cells and also subcellular
structure and you can run analysis
either in 3d or in
3d which allows to identify here
organoid objects and also identify
objects inside objects like it can find
count cells inside different organoids
it can count also life at dead cells or
different type of cells inside of each
organoids
so in this example we run a 3d analysis
so in this experiment we've done
toxicity studies
of
a number of
anti-cancer compounds which were known
to cause lung toxicity one example is
ibrutinib so you can see those cells
become dead and it's positive for
ethereum from a dimer and you run 3d
analysis and you define those cells
and here you can absorb concentration
dependency and you can see that actually
in 3d
this system was more sensitive to toxic
effects than in 2d which was done with
the same cells
so to
elaborate more how this analysis done so
in this example you can see
so that individual
images in a zip stack analyzed
separately and then this
information is converted in 3d space so
you can get this 3d space rendering and
more important you can get measurements
so in this example we analyze liver
spheroids treated or untreated treated
with liver toxic compound and
stained is like dead stain and you can
see different liver toxic compound and
changes in phenotype and you can
actually quantitate this changes by 3d
analysis so you can quantitate number of
life and dead cells and also in this
case like you can quantitate volumes
like a volume of life cells this
cytoplasm of life cells this is nuclei
and you can see dramatic changes these
different compounds so we characterize
number of 3d measurements for phenotypic
changes
and defines that some measurements
actually follow for parametric um those
response
curve and
these those are include like counting
life cells or counting their
volume or intensities
and some other measurements like let's
say steroid volume or number of dead
cells may also describe kinetic changes
but may or may not follow this four
parametric distribution
so when you actually use
multi-parametric analysis
it gives you more opportunity to fully
describe the changes which you see
so this is example of intestinal
organoids it's my nice intestinal
organoids so this is a 4x magnification
on 20x objective so this is live stain
so you can see all details here very
nicely and also we
developed this like that essay for
different applications so here we try to
model inflammation by addition of
cytokines tnf and il17
and here we
did toxicity studies in anti-cancer
agents cisplatin and doxorbisin
and we use livedata analysis and
staining to actually quantitate the
number and ratio of life and dead stains
so here example of for higher
magnification analysis of intestinal
organoids so those cells are actually
internal expression of
of serum induced cells and you can do
analysis and
provide quantitation of those insulin
expression cells in different condition
so this is another example of organoid
with
staining and with imaging and also
analysis must
so you can also reveal complex structure
of different organize and convert it
into 3d space
so
now i would like to describe brain
organoids uh so this is very important
model obviously for understanding
diseases and it could be used
by taking samples in this pluripotent
stem cells
derived from a blood of patients or
the mutation could be genetically
engineered by crisp permutation
so those brain organoids were derived
from induced pluripotent stem cell using
noble incline caster method and also we
use kit from stem cell technologies
uh so you can see growth and development
of
those
organoids over from
extended period of time
so
this method includes
starting from induced pluripotent stem
cells and then cultures them in a
u-shaped law attachment plates and then
placing those organoids into material
gel and
continuous culture of those over kind of
long long time so we culture them for
five months for now
and so this is the example of organoids
they grow pretty big
and this is
a staining of
life organoids with calcium dye
so this is another figure showing size
and
this is
a machine learning based analysis of
those different organoids over the time
so we use this deep learning based
segmentation of different organoids with
different shape and we can use machine
learning based classification of shape
of those organoids
so right now we're working on
development of calcium
imaging protocols and this is somewhat
challenging in this big organoids
because
this
spikes appear in in
different places and you
need to capture those but we can
actually capture those using time lapse
imaging and we can actually
further analyze those
using region of interest
so we also proceed with conventional
staining so this is staining this soaks
too and here you can see a better
tubulin expression
so this is
expression of different markers in this
stock
and here is the maximum projection image
and so right now kind of we still follow
this culture and trying to kind of
develop methods for better analysis
on the
related note i would like to describe
some of our older study which we have
done not with brain organoids but with
neurospheroids
those were from stemonics
those structures are kind of not having
that complex
uh morphology but they were having very
actually consistent and spontaneous
beating profile and we were able to
actually use our instruments to a
serious
recording of calcium
flexes and see effect of different
compounds slowing down or speeding up
or kind of
effect of some toxic compounds
and
so here you see an example of
modification of pattern with different
neurotransmitters
and here you can see example how you can
use software here is flipper instrument
software for analysis
so we have used this method before to
identify a
neurotoxic effect of different
compounds
and so right now here working on
developing it this method using actually
this mature and developed
brain organoids
so i would like to
switch now to cancer research and
describe how we use phytoplankton
imaging to characterize phenotypic
changes in cancer steroids and organoids
so
he worked this cell line derived
spheroids
so this is pollen cancer transferred and
deforms those using law attachment plate
and treated with different compounds and
development and how we can characterize
those different phenotypes by using
software
right now we have collaboration with
academic researchers from tulane
university where we use patient-derived
xenograft
um
cells
and organoids to study effect of
different drugs
so we use
cell line which was derived from primary
tumor from triple negative cancer tumor
sample and he form organoids from those
and treats those with different drugs
and this is example of
hemorrhoids three untreated and treated
with remedies seen and this is how
phenotype changes so we use like that
stain here
and also quantitation of
these images
so this is example of
a response of
to different drugs in those tumors so
you can see actually that
for
taxol
it's much higher effective concentration
that for
those other um
new promising drugs
and this actually finding was
corresponding to actually clinical data
so which gives a great implication for
possibly using this type of essays and
high content analysis
for
development of best
therapy for specific patients
so this is another example of
hemorrhoids stained for different cancer
markers like
icathrin and cd44
and you see also modulation of those
marker expression
after compounds treatment
and you can run analysis similar to
essay described before where you can
find different spirits and also
characterize them for life that and
expression of different markers you can
also do multi um
spheroid assessment in this multi cavity
plates and look for
clonality of different tumors
in addition i'm going to uh to describe
several other types of
3d models and analysis how you can do
this and this is example of angiogenesis
sprouting in
organic chip for me meadows plate so
those
angiogenic sprouts were growing through
through the matrix from a
tube in of those plates
and
the degree of
this grows and also respond to different
compounds you can quantitate by analysis
so you can actually define and
quantitate so sprouts and number of
cells inside of those sprouts
and to do so you again take a z stock
and then convert it into 3d space and
then define number of those sprouts as
well as their lengths and number of
cells
so this is another example so this is
near
and this is
cardiac steroids and they beaten in a
culture and you can actually
treat them with different compounds and
report calcium flux activity
and this recorded activity you can
analyze those reporting and define
different parameters like amplitude
frequency distance between peaks or
other parameters
so this is example from 2d and 3d
culture of
cardiac
cells
stem cell-derived cardiac cells and you
see a fact of different compounds which
cause this specific pattern which was
associated with
severe cardiac toxicity
and this is how software defines those
peaks and also primary and secondary
effects
so right now we're working with cardiac
organoids
and those organoids were derived from
induced pluripotent stem cells and you
can see this calcium fluxes and also
actually mechanical beating in an in a
culture
and you can record it using imaging
method
and you can visualize those speaks and
quantitate their parameters
and also you can do
toxicity assessment by staining and
imaging so here for example you
do imagine and come it says compound
effect over
time treatment with different drugs
so now i would like to describe a little
bit more uh the image analysis software
and also describe how you can use
machine learning tools for better
analysis
so in this example we use cell painting
essay which
paint different
compounds different components of cells
and you can get
this feature extraction by
analysis and
measure
not only a number of features but also
their relative position and
intensity and colloquialization
so this analysis is very complex and
gives you a lot of readouts so to take
full advantage of it we use hierarchical
clustering analysis with the help of
core live analytics and
strata miner software
so we use this workflow for complex
analysis of
different compounds and different
phenotypic effects
more interestingly we also done label
free image analysis using machine
learning
algorithms
so so some organoids
could be kind of a
simple shape like round but still it's a
lot of complexity and a lot of image
artifacts which can cause
errors in analysis and also you can have
complexity of your labware or
complexity of your culture
and so it is
very difficult to develop actually the
method which would account for all of
those features but if you use this
machine learning algorithm so this
become
very easy so all you have to do
you have your training sets
and you define the features which you're
looking for and also you define them
features which you want to exclude
and with your iteration you can have
pretty good analysis
so we have done it for lan organoids
for intestinal organoids and even
for intestinal organoids we define
different organoids like differentiated
from undifferentiated from dead
organoids by their different features
i defined growth and development of
stem cell colonies
and also monitoring of growth of
organoids
during the time
finally we use it for
those
patient-derived organoids so we can
actually quantitate and define the drug
effect over time even without
staining and so this is very helpful if
you want to
attribute the third dimension not only
different compounds and different
concentration but also time response
so last but not least i would like to
describe
uh the automation of the
culture and all complex
3d and biology workflow
so at molecular devices we build this
innovation center
which includes a number of different
instruments
and
which enable
automation of different steps of
workflow not only analysis so it
includes cell culture cell monitoring
media exchange compound edition
and also scheduling
of multiple processes
this
complex contains some molecular devices
instrument like
image express
system and also
plate reader and plate washer
but also it contains
some external vendors like this beckman
culture biomac i7 or automated incubator
iconic as well as centrifuge and the
robot
so he developed a number of protocols
which allow to automate entire cell
culture so you can see here how the
robot picks up plate from um
automated
incubator and puts it into the beckman
instrument
then inside the beckman instrument those
plates get picked up and the lid removed
and then these plates started to be fed
by media so he developed protocol in
collaboration with beckman which allowed
gentle media exchange with this material
domes and this pipette and then off
center not to distort those material
domes and it actually works pretty
nicely
so in this example you can see again the
fitting of
organoids so in this case this is
addition of medium
and after feeding is done so then plate
actually
goes to the back of
instrument where it's picked up by robot
so interestingly we also uh
develop protocols for plating of cells
inside these material domes so you can
see how
actually automated process
easily
performs those
material droplets which is not so easy
to do by hands
so we use
pretty shield
plates
and we
do this process very successfully
after that we allow it to solidify and
then add media on the top and it goes
back to incubator
so in addition when we develop a
separate protocols where monitoring and
imaging could be done automatically so
the robot takes out
plates
and put it automatically into
our imaging system and then it activates
the
protocols which we previously developed
and so you can do this monitoring
process
without human participation
then analysis
is done automatically which can monitor
growth and development of different
organoids and so you can actually
develop an entire protocol which would
enable automated
maintenance and setup and also essay of
your organoids
so this is pretty much it what i wanted
to describe so i would like to
acknowledge my co-workers from molecular
devices especially angelina lim
and also our
collaborators from different
institutions who help us to work with
different organoids
so thank you so much for your attention
if you will have additional question
please
go to our website moleculardevices.com
or please contact us directly and if you
need some protocols or if you need more
information thank you so much again for
your attention
thank you aksana for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q and a
portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
let's get started our first question is
can this methodology be adopted for
fixed tissue
yes thank you so much for that question
this is very important question and in
fact yes that could be easily adopted
for
um for fixed tissues it just need to
include 16 steps into the process
so we have done it we have done it for
cell painting essay using automation and
we're now developing a protocol for
spheroids and organoids
all right thank you uh next question
what are the main benefits of machine
learning analysis for organoids
this is also an interesting question so
there are two main approaches you can
either
define
the changes and objects
how you see it and what you expect to
see for example you can use your own
judgment to define
positive or negative cells for
some marker and you set up thresholds
accordingly
to get your analysis and quantitation
but you can use a different approach
which would include machine learning and
this is especially useful for
for the samples where you either don't
really ensure what to expect or with the
high complexity of samples or with the
samples like
which you get they use in transmitted
light those don't have much changes in
intensity but have a lot of subtle
changes which actually machine learning
algorithm may spot much better and
analyze more efficiently so to do this
kind of analysis you have your positive
sample and your negative sample and you
train the software uh which
features
belong to a
standard control phenotype or as to
change phenotype and we get really good
results with many samples especially
with transmitted light samples
all right thank you
next question this is a multi-part
question
how thick is the tissue
what type of microfluidic chip do you
use
and how often do you change the media
actually we don't use microfluidic chip
with the exception of mimita's plate we
have some protocol developed for
mimita's plate
we use
this
automation and technique mostly using
standard plates
all right
um thank you next question
do you have some 3d culturing technique
in between between the 24 w plates and
incubation can you do 3d cell culture
inside incubators
okay so the first part of question is
very kind of
relevant so we
done this
techniques in 24 well plates and you can
do
this automation automated seeding of
material dome automated media exchange
or compound treatment and then you can
do imaging so the imaging is pretty
efficient in 24 well played just you may
be limited with it is to choose the
objective
uh so we have we have
done 3d cell culture inside incubator
but we we cannot do any liquid handling
or media exchange inside the incubators
with our setup it's two different
instruments and we use robotic arm to
move between those instruments
all right thank you
um next question
do the organoids contain sensors for rf
signals such as nano cfos technology or
is it based on piezo electrical bases of
the polymers or advanced materials used
with the cells
uh so this is um um
probably more difficult question to
answer we don't have any sensor
is
currently in our organized but this is
actually good call to implement for
future essay development
and so the sensor would be helpful for
multiple applications
all right thank you
next question
what are the implementations of this
kind of automation over bioinformatics
uh so we haven't used
bioinformatics
very extensively in this setup so
the one approach we use for kind of data
management we use corelight technology
um
collaborative platforms so we have
done some data management which coming
out of imaging instrument but yeah
bioinformatics of course it's very
important tool and would be very useful
especially when you run
a big screen so this is something we
need to implement more
all right
um next question how reliable is the
automated media exchange
so they have done number of testing and
we found that it is very reliable so we
use beckman instruments our
collaborators are using hamilton
instrument and in fact this all
automated media handling techniques are
very reliable but may
request some adjustment especially if
you deal with
material or other variety of liquids
all right thank you
um and it looks like we have one more
question
which measurements are the most useful
for comparison of organoids and
different treatments
this is also a good question so we have
done some characterization of multiple
measurements so
there is complex phenotypic changes
going on in organoids and other complex
3d systems so it is
different number of objects different
size distribution of size
and also kind of shape and intensity of
different
staining markers but most important we
found that
it is important to count objects count
cells actually inside organoids and not
only count them but also characterize
them for
like life dead or positive or negative
differentiated and differentiated and so
they
typically characterize
10 to 15 of different readouts from
imaging
but we found that some of them have more
um those response
dependencies than other so for example
like counting live cells or counting
like positive or negative cells uh we
found to be the most reliable marker but
other readouts also help in um
assessment of different phenotypic
changes
all right thank you oksana do you have
any final comments for our audience
so thank you so much for joining so this
is very exciting area of
investigation and for development and we
working hard to implement different
methods and
improve our instruments to
meet
growing customer needs so if you have
any suggestions or additional questions
about
methods or technology or instruments
please email us we'll be happy to answer
your questions thank you
all right
well thank you again oksana for your
time today and your important research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor molecular devices for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
until next time goodbye